o ator jon hamm confesso dizer já uma
coisa
é o pequeno e o novo grande eu vi fiquei
perplexo como é que eu vou dar a volta a
isto mas não ia perder oportunidade de
estar aqui este círculo vermelho
enfim que eu vejo na televisão e que eu
vejo na internet e que o fez china é
extraordinário para partilhar convosco
cumprindo aquilo que eu saiba aquilo que
eu fui aprendendo que também não é
manifestamente muito mas dizer já duas
premissas primeiro cônsul em dinheiro e
portanto apesar de vir aqui falar aqui
um pouco sobre tecnologia nada de coisas
muito complicadas ou não pressionava e
segundo que aquilo que vos vou te
mostrar
não fui eu que desenvolvi eu aliás
assumir uma posição de sair dos teus
relativamente esta tecnologia e busca
todas as entropias e mais algumas que eu
consegui encontrar para perceber se vale
ou não volto pensando eu quero fazer
aqui uma primeira experiência e fazer
aquilo que no inquérito e dizer qualquer
coisa como a quem seus perguntar se
sabem alguma coisa se possuem alguma
coisa ou se são alguma coisa que são
alguém que todos nós tenhamos resposta
sempre responder a uma série de coisas
mas eu nem vou fazer essa pergunta e vos
dizer que desenharam um conjunto de
calça e metafísico extremamente complexo
não vale a pena agora está aqui
partilhar convosco eu digo que todos vós
todos vós porque sair assim permitem
dizer são alguém subiam ou sabem alguma
coisa
transpondo isto para a área da
tecnologia dizer que quando nós
interagimos com o sistema informático
temos que fazer prova quem não somos
seres humanos quando interagimos com o
sistema informático nós somos seres
digitais como é que eu consiga diminuir
esse hiato entre quem eu sou enquanto
ser humano e ganham soprando um sistema
informático e então a tecnologia ea
indústria da informática é f tem um
conjunto de soluções que está aí é
proporcional e o primeiro e passou a
semana toda poderosa estrangeirismo que
nós nos habituámos a conviver que é vez
também houve também com letras em letras
com letras grandes nem letras pequenas
que têm que ser mudada com muita
é prioridade ou não que me permita
aceder ao multibanco ou comprar as
cápsulas que eu comprar o seguro será
veiculada às cápsulas do café teve todas
estas passou antes torna tornam
complicada a nossa vida
acham necessário elas são necessárias
porque porque eu preciso fazer prova
tenho sou branco esse mesmo sistema
informático que se chama pode ser enfim
website pode ser uma máquina pode ser
qualquer tipo de interação com um
digital que eu possa ver o cruzeiro
devido a todos nós é que consigamos
mobilizar essas mesmas passou antes que
deixou mais compridas e mais complexas
enfim então nossa memória ram e de casa
remobilizar passou diz em vez de ser
aplicado a outras coisas que elas fossem
fazer mas é também o espírito que nós
façamos isso e consigamos que tenhamos
ano serão criados antes irá alterar
essas pacientes com uma maior
prejudicado porque porque aqui o show
junto complicados que já estão na china
e fazer um saiba qualquer coisa eu vou
roubar as nossas passou a 0 não só nós
temos que mobilizar e temos que ir
alterando com maior periodicidade como
elas são cada vez mais complexas e não
deixou de pedir nas folhas entre o tempo
passou depressa passou por aqui uma
vassoura não ser que entretanto o que eu
queria tomar um café
só quero nunca foi cumprida os campos de
guará bico para tomar um café mais nada
do que isso então a indústria diz assim
era mais um problema nós trazemos outra
inovação é que eu vou dar aqui uma
palavra muito complicada que é o
tocantins
isto quer dizer desmistificando isto um
código sms que mandam para o telemóvel e
juntamente com o passar do tempo em que
ocorrem as fêmeas ou um cartão matriz em
haia de batalha naval que tem o a 23 e o
volante mesmo lá coloquei por nada e
então assim disse para la plata mas eu
tenho um pastor que eu tenho lembrará
passou é desse tamanho com letras e
números e alfanumérico 160 eu já não sei
se estas entre porque já tive que mudar
e agora mas eu queria nunca falei isso
que oito marca feio tá esquecendo o
telemóvel não tenho mas mandou e mail
então o que estamos aqui verificar é que
todas estas lógicas de redundância ou de
auxílio que a indústria está a propor a
todos nós cidadãos tornam vida ainda
mais complicada
tudo aquilo que ela deveria ser mais uma
vez o rio eu só quero tomar um café
então indústria diz assim não faz mal se
não é que o que eu saí que é pastor
senão é que o sul que é o toque no
cartão
então é que o sul em impressão digital
apenas o sim à paz ou eu posso ou não
posso não figurar nela é é a toca eu
posso não ter as bolas eu sou eu
sabemos que essa capacidade de nos
identificar em que fisicamente pela
nossa edição digital pela íris ou até
pela estrutura do nosso de nossos vasos
capilares as coisas complicaram-se mas
não vale a pena estarmos agora aqui
falar mas há um problema precisa sempre
um ar goleiro precisa sempre que o vá
colocar meu dedo
o caro o meu olho ou fazer outra coisa
qualquer para garantir que sou eu mesmo
então aonde se tornar complicado do
ponto de vista de implementação além de
tornar custoso do ponto de vista do
custo a problemas legais e fiz alguns
juristas aqui nessa rua sabe explicar
muito melhor do que eu
do ponto de vista de fazer uma base da
ti com a informação que minha sou eu não
é informação que eu sair eu sul
mas é uma coisa que sou eu bola cá bola
lá
mas se destas três tentativas nada
funciona ou nada é perfeito
como é que nós descansamos esta volta e
foi que eu tive o privilégio de
trabalhar com conjunto engenheiros
informáticos que certo dia me disseram
assim nós gostávamos trabalhar em
londres comportamentais se identificar
na mim não caiu sul como eu ajo como eu
interajo que mais toca mais por mim que
eu não percebo que vocês não dizer então
fizeram todos os cálculos matemáticos
coisas complicadíssima 73 v
na prática o chavão dizer um sim quando
nós nem interagir com o sistema
informático fala sem força
em autenticação digital com forte e
minha autenticação confortei prova que
eu estou a fazer pratos tema que eu sou
eu quem diz ser
passou o toco edson teria numa escala de
menos forte para mais forte o que é
facto é que à medida que o tempo passa
por mais forte que seja essa
autenticação que eu estou a fazer ela
vai tendencialmente de cheia de força de
mudar o cariz político
eu meto por absurdo uma pastora um toca
e o meu olho não se de qualquer prémio
autenticar para o sistema
eu estou a tentar eu já estou a
trabalhar dentro do sistema é o toque
feminino também fui tomar café ganhou
outra em alguém por trás e começar a
trabalhar num sistema de temas a doação
eu não sabia quem não sabe e é esse isso
problema é que nós tentamos resolver
como é que eu consigo forma totalmente
transparente portuguesa por esta palavra
transparente por seu livro marketing que
nem sabemos o que se está passar
totalmente transparente outro setor e de
forma persistente fazer com que a força
dessa autenticação não cresça à medida
que o tempo passa mas aumenta sem que eu
peço que o torcedor tenha mais uma
passou ou mais um tucano o planeta sei
lá
o dna do cabelo coisa que valha para
ficar pronto o sistema como isso é feito
como foi campeão três comportamentais a
trecho que eu saiba evento o metrô mas
que eu saiba a 3
a forma como eu falo identificámos de
forma inequívoca e ao grito já pensados
e fiáveis e capazes de identificar a mim
como ruim apenas pela forma como eu falo
o problema é o canal o plano é dizer sim
eu posso falar muito mas o grito nem
assim consegue sempre lá é sempre o
objetivo era falar ao telemóvel uma
chamada não for nada especial como é que
isso funciona
tendencialmente tem esse problema a
forma como eu ando juros
eu tinha alguma cepticismo relativamente
a 2010 mas o que é facto é com câmeras
que são colocadas em sítios estratégicos
de uma sala como esta a forma como eu
ando e depois construir modelos
tridimensionais conseguem identificar a
mim mesmo dizem meus eu não vi nada que
funcionários com grau de fiabilidade
capaz enfim aliás o que se diz é que os
algoritmos tenham melhor filme ainda
muito baixo
o que não é e praticava na vida real e
todos nós não queremos dizer sim bolas
mas sou eu
boas mas eu tenho um sapato tornamos mas
eu tenho aqui comigo você tem que usar o
grito tem que ser capazes de identificar
um conjunto de um conjunto de situações
eu sei o que é aquilo que nós minha
empresa que representa a desenvolveu e
temos muita gente internacional sobre
reforma como técnico é normal jogar mas
a forma como eu estou é teclar nas
teclas descansou essa agora de manhã
então fiquei muito cheio de microchip
força teclado uma certa forma à tarde
não estou você estiver em cima dos
joelhos até claro ou se estiver com o
telemóvel ea tecla só com uma mão ou se
eu tiver um dedo partido ou se foram
sair com alguém e beber uma cerveja
assim um outro enfim ea coisa não fica
se desenvolver
eu vou escrever vou teclar de forma
diferente e aí está a beleza do
algoritmo da cabeceira da tecnologia nós
envolvente
não interessa o que se escreve não
interessa em que dilma se inscreva
não interessa se inscrever amanhã à
noite
se quiser não interessa se eu estou a
utilizar este teclado ou este teclado ou
aquilo
não interessa se eu estou a partilhar
computadores com pessoas e agora estou a
jogar depois destruí lo gastou r 70
porque é completamente agnóstica tudo
isto eu pergunto aos 15 anos ela diz
assim uma coisa que se chama memória
muscular
inventamos existem pelo menos umas
coisas sobre ele ingeriu desta coisa
então a morena clara diz que a forma
como vou te claro ea forma como eu
combino série de teclas a força com que
eu coloco a pressionar a tecla e alargar
o tempo que eu moro entre uma tecla e
outra esse conjunto de variáveis
vamos conseguir um sistema vai conseguir
criar um perfil para mim que não vai
identificar
isto é tudo muito giro mas amanhã
isso eu tenho um braço partido em natal
eu tenho que ser justo é claro forma
diferente então o perfil que eu tenha
criado pra mim é dinâmico não é estático
não é algo imutável eu fui aprendendo
com a forma como eu vôo teclado e isso
na prática quer dizer o que quer dizer
que eu preciso a mesma do espaço quer
dizer que eu preciso a mesma gostou quem
quer dizer que eu preciso a mesma região
trilhas por isso casa ou uma combinação
multifatorial e fim destas destas todas
mas depois de entrar dentro daquele
sistema
depois de entrar dentro do perímetro de
segurança como se costuma dizer que o
contínuo é garantir que quem está a
interagir com o sistema efetivamente a
pessoa deve ser quando só tem pique para
vezes o que acontece quando o sistema
detecta que não sou eu
as coisas podem acontecer eu pode fechar
a sessão eu pode humilhar o irmão eu
posso pedir outra passou o ano pode
pedir um nome entre um ponto eu quiser
esta tecnologia nós é excelente esta não
sendo a tecnologia que nós como já o pão
e água para viver diz que aquela não
gostar mendo desenvolver e porque é que
eu passo para uma sonda para a minha
apresentação para dizer que não sendo um
engenheiro ou alguém que gosta
essencialmente de sair da sua zona de
conforto e quando nós criamos esta
empresa
temos as mesmas coisas todas membros os
bulls chanceleiros green field lemos o
se caros e lentos tudo isso e sendo
assim como é que eu vou cozinhar tudo
está a menina como é que eu vou
conseguir fazer com que o pequeno
sagrada como é que eu vou conseguir que
uma pequena empresa - e ter aulas
consiga lutar com grandes multinacionais
ea quatro características que na minha
opinião em wau wau na minha opinião
fazem com que o pequeno seja o novo
grande
primeiro é ágil vamos conseguir muito
muito ágil e imagem que estudar e bar
cantor controle
o piloto quer virar de uma hora
para virar em uma grande empresa aqui
onde mora primeiro que alguma coisa
aconteça aqui demora uma startup uma
empresa pequena qualquer coisa diz faz
dois cima do gol prazo e nós conseguimos
mudar nós conseguimos alterar o rumo das
coisas
depois a relevância
eu sinto que estou fazer alguma coisa eu
sinto que eu estou é é a fazer aprender
é algo que vai mudar o im
é algo que vai trazer enfim uma
conseqüência temos assim e não é algo
que mexe absolutamente quase nada na
direcção daquela empresa na direção de
que o projeto seria paixão
falamos aqui de manhã achamos
fundamental conseguir levantar manhã
entender que ela é citada e ter aquela
vontade dele e chegar lá ea coisa não
funcionar e eu tenho é simples mas a
maneira de tocar outra vez porque fiz
vai ter que funcionar toda essa paixão
vê nós sermos existentes ou como alguém
dizia eu insisti insisti e nunca desisti
e conseguir fazer as coisas acontecer
essa paixão é fundamental e eu vim dizer
os que têm de estar rodeado das pessoas
certas nós não sabemos todos nós já
sabemos tudo e e depois é capaz irado
comunhão da capacidade de conseguirmos
alguma forma de ver os ensinamentos de
pessoas mais velhas mais novas que está
por cima nós apaixonados ao nosso lado
quer que seja os que nada têm a ver com
a tecnologia pessoas que nada têm a ver
com aquilo que nós fazemos é que nós
conseguimos ir com o ponto e conseguimos
ter aquela capacidade do globo não é do
ovo de colombo que com o que temos à
disposição
conseguimos montar uma coisa não se eu
conseguir fazer um projeto nós o
conseguisse nossa paixão em fazer algo
que nos dá realmente prazer